and behind the numbers associated with
the pandemic of course are thousands of
individuals and their families dealing
with heartbreak dealing with isolation
and in a growing number of cases dealing
with grief
David beg no is focusing on some of
those stories a fourth member of a
family who lives in the northeastern
part of the US has died from coronavirus
seven members of the fusco family have
all tested positive for the virus
meanwhile in Southern California one of
the youngest individuals to contract the
virus has passed away 34 year-old
Jeffrey goos Arion a cancer survivor who
had recently visited Disney World and
Universal Studios in Florida died
Thursday in California also in
California there were images of another
patient in an isolation chamber being
loaded off of a private jet by workers
in hazmat suits it was very very anxious
the 65 year old patient was transported
to Los Angeles from Aruba where he
tested positive for the virus the flight
was chartered by jet rescue air
ambulance and was lined in plastic to
pilots a doctor and a paramedic were on
board we started an IV and we are
putting all of our health care workers
at the front line some of them are going
to get sick in New York medical student
Ruth Howell has seen the human suffering
firsthand there are a lot of people out
there who have a lung disease or high
blood pressure or something else that's
weakened their immune system there are
more vulnerable to this for CBS this
morning i'm david beg know here in new
york it is so important don't you think
to put a face on what is happening in
this country for people to understand
how serious this is I think some people
still don't understand this is a very
serious crisis that man was transported
to but if you're not taking precautions
right now look at that and start that's
why they say stay home stay safe